[Musique]
telle qu'elle se présente cette décision
de la préfecture semble bien justifié
par ce spectacle
voilà ce que peut voir un touriste qui
débarque garde une un café tous les
trois mètres mais de 3,75 mètres 25 fois
la distance n'est ce pas tomber dans
l'excès dans l'autre pourquoi 75 m parce
que 100 mètres nous est apparu pour une
grande ville comme paris une licence un
peu trop longue pour satisfaire les
besoins de la de notre clientèle 50 m et
i don't lie to me sens vraiment trop
courte parce que l'impression de de
l'entassement aurait continué à être
gênant maintenant 75 mètres de distance
moyenne qui nous convient l'arrêté de la
préfecture n'est pas une décision
unilatérale il est le fruit de
négociations entre les autorités et les
représentants de la profession de
méchantes langues vont même jusqu'à
affirmer que les cafetiers aurait poussé
à la roue pour limiter la concurrence et
revaloriser leur front ainsi tout le
monde est content il compris bien sûr le
comité de lutte contre l'alcoolisme
quant aux clients il est préférable
d'avoir des bistrots qui se côtoient
d'ailleurs depuis ce sont le client le
client peut choisir le lieu où il va
consommer que de world et the big toe
qui parait-il actuellement sont
inoccupés par des gens non malades car
pasteur a dit la meilleure des boissons
et le vin à la beauté pasteur mais n'est
pas un idéal à l'amour et à la santé et
le christ
you le pen la france est un pays
producteur et noblesse oblige grands
consommateurs de en 1954 avec alou ahmad
ezz sur les bouilleurs de cru l'état
engage les hostilités puis le
législateur s'en mêle pour lutter contre
l'alcoolisme il faut limiter la
tentation pour le public
en 1955 à loi debré instaure les zones
protégées
les commerces déjà existants conservent
leurs droits
mais désormais il est interdit de
s'installer près des écoles des stades
des hôpitaux des églises et même des
cimetières interdit également les abords
des prisons face à la santé un seul
bistrot antérieure à la promulgation de
la loi il bénéficie des droits acquis
mais n'aura pas deux voisins depuis 1914
on ne crée plus de café en france on les
transfère c'est à dire qu'on vend la
licence en 1914 il y avait 900 mille
débits de boissons il n'en reste plus
actuellement que deux cent soixante
mille en moyenne un débit pour 280
personnes
l'actuelle législation porte à réduire
ce chiffre à un débit pour 450 habitants
que les cafetiers ne s'illusionne pas la
mesure prise par la préfecture de paris
si elle était étendue à toute la france
fera par la force des choses disparaître
de nouveaux établissements pourtant le
bistrot le bistrot d'aujourd'hui n'est
plus la sowaer d'hier les français
boivent moins c'est connu mais le café
reste tout de même un rôle et humains
indispensables pour bon nombre de
français
ouais quand elle était en faveur avec
tous ces belles de glace
on connaissait tous les bistrots et puis
tous ces voeux gage fait quand ils l'ont
voudront des vents a perdu notre
quartier parce que moi je fais un buzz
deuxième on y est on a vécu là dedans
une érudition voyait au fond le bistrot
pour vous c'est quoi bon et c'est une
réunion de copains qu'on peut discuter
les bureaux de tabac rade parce qu une
ambiance où on joue à 4,21 à ce moment
là cette épaule 4 21 c est l envie
la bge est le délit est bien celle qu'on
l'a dans la roue des cendriers nous
c'était la bhl père veillesse maintenant
que tout est démoli pouvoir les maisons
neuves
on se croit sur un treuil pu trouver la
pression comme la ligne maginot